c'est un cadeau de départ empoisonné que
l'administration trump laisse au yémen
des sanctions américaines qui entreront
en vigueur le 19 janvier la veille de la
prise de fonction du nouveau président
objectifs avancés par washington
lutter contre le terrorisme et
l'influencé de l'iran dans le pays
les désignations vise à tenir en sarre à
la responsable de ses actes terroristes
y compris les attaques transfrontalières
menaçant les populations civiles les
infrastructures et la navigation
commerciale
elle vise également à faire progresser
les efforts pour parvenir un yémen
pacifique souverain et uni à la fois
exempt d'ingérence iraniennes et en paix
avec ses voisins
trois dirigeants du groupe rebelle sont
également désormais inscrits sur cette
liste
une décision fermement condamné par les
responsables outils je pense que les
négociations seront grandement affecté
par cette décision et année aujourd'hui
les états unis veulent bloquer toute
voie menant à l'arrêt de l'agression
contre le yémen et aux négociations
le groupe rebelles contrôlent
actuellement le nord ouest du yémen et
sa capitale sanaa l'iran grand ennemi de
washington lui sert d'appui politique
majeure de son côté le royaume saoudien
à la tête d'une coalition militaire
soutient le gouvernement yéménite face
aux outils c'est donc sans surprise que
ryad a salué la décision américaine tout
comme le gouvernement d'athènes soutenu
par le royaume saoudien
al'inverse de téhéran qui voit dans
cette liste noire un processus ayant
perdu toute légitimité
après de nombreuses années de
bombardements du yémen
ils ont aujourd'hui atteint un point où
ils doivent cacher leur incapacité
derrière de telles actions qui sont
joués à l'échec mais qu'on amour à dire
que le temps est maintenant loin où ils
devront venir négocier avec des groupes
responsables et complètement nationaux
dans différents pays y compris le yémen
ces actions n'ont aucune valeur sérieuse
dans les derniers jours du régime
américain à la maison blanche efficace
pour de nombreuses organisations donald
trump cherche à frapper un grand coup
diplomatique contre l'iran avant
l'arrivée à la maison blanche de joe
biden qui a affirmé vouloir renouer le
dialogue avec la république islamique
un dialogue que ces sanctions rendent
désormais plus difficile ce qui ne
manque pas d'inquiéter la population
yéménite
en effet la madeleine nous espérons que
les états unis et d'autres pays pourront
soutenir les efforts de l'envoyé des
nations unies pour apporter la paix mais
la décision de désigner les rebelles
houthi comme co terroriste rendra les
choses plus compliquées
si les rebelles houthi sont inscrits sur
la liste des groupes terroristes
cela augmentera les souffrances des
civils au yémen les organisations
humanitaires cesseront leur travail et
l'aide humanitaire diminuera
considérablement à l'exception des
organisations qui ont déjà cessé leur
travail au yémen il ya un certain temps
si cette déclaration est adoptée elle
provoquera une énorme crise humanitaire
et les civils en paieront le prix la
peur d'une aggravation de la crise
humanitaire est également partagé par
l'onu qui craint des effets négatifs sur
l'importation de denrées alimentaires et
ce au pire moment
le pays est frappé par la famine depuis
2014 et le début du conflit
une crise sanitaire qui a déjà fait au
moins plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
victimes